so now they have us feeling all like
warm and cuddly and silver on blood
board from software we go swing real
gothic it's blood-borne shoe announces
the title of it and we quickly learned
this is Project peace yes from software
is the game that I guess leaked via
whoever was at 4chan I think I thought
we a little gift thing last week yeah
this looks pretty great again another
tone term a CG thing short and looks I
don't know there's something just from
software I don't know something about it
you just think they're probably gonna
make something special it will be
special I mean at the end of a like it's
good you know it's gonna be hardcore
right he knows me super gory and
hopefully it looks as pretty as you know
these think the CG trailers made out to
be and the creature design just like
real gruesome but also you know like
resonates with the architecture of this
place and like you said the tone trailer
here really sets that tone and you know
that that sort of dark place that then
has that challenge that you know you you
delve into and you know you're getting
yourself into trouble dude you know I
mean Dark Souls and Demon's Souls you
know they're games that I haven't played
all the way through to the end but what
I play them I've enjoyed very very much
I know that their hardest balls which is
why I haven't played them all the way
cuz I have other things to do like I
have time to like do all that but you
know there's so much fun and yeah I
can't wait for this ready to go
I absolutely I'm sorry I'm being a bit
quiet I'm just trying to confirm a story
I'll come back to in a minute
not at all Danny of course please find
us the information
so blood-borne here from from software
and rim very very grim but not the
grimmest thing we saw I don't think
we're gonna get to some combat accents
you